I got no no Mom no Mom it wasn't the
actual devil no they were just dressed
as the devil mom Ben after that
whispered into Jennifer like hey there
and she replied with stop look more
friendly Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck
are very well aware of the viral memes
that came out of Grammy's night and now
a source tells E.T how the couple feels
about it it's a real thing the actor
sour facial expressions exploded on the
internet during Sunday's ceremony and it
turns out JLo and Ben knew they were
going viral in real time we're trying to
get some can you see if we can get in
the papers
our source says JLo showed her hubby a
few photos that night and he just
brushed it off which was echoed by a
seat filler who allegedly saw the same
thing it's funny actually that you
talked about Ben Affleck because I was
seated right next to him oh right next
to him and JLo I was at the table and
JLo actually handed her phone to Ben and
said hey honey look at this meme that's
circulating about you so they were so
well aware during the Grammys about it
as for the couple's reaction well our
source says Ben's not phase in fact
they're not even really paying attention
to all that but get this Jen actually
thinks some of the memes are funny it
was so funny Jayla was texting I didn't
know who but
people about the meme and sending it to
her friends what can I tell you we're
just having a good time one person joked
however bad of a day you're having I
promise you're not as miserable as Ben
Affleck at the Grammys right now you
know it's wild to think about it that
way Jokes Aside another source tells E.T
that despite any funny facial
expressions the newlyweds actually had a
fun date night out as for why Ben looked
you know a little low energy well it's
because the guy's been busy quote
they've both been very busy working on
several projects and Ben was feeling
tired I'm gonna do our best overall The
Source says JLo had a great time and
wanted her hubby to be excited to be
there but she understood where he was
coming from Jed knows Ben is a great
husband and they still made sure to have
a good night together
foreign